This lecture and the next are probably
the most explicitly philosophical
lectures of the course.
Then we moved into psychometrics and
biological psychology really,
and those are going to be the most
scientific lectures of the course.
I was thinking this morning about when I
was preparing this lecture about
why I approach these topics this way.
I guess part of the answer is probably
that it isn't.
It isn't clear that the study of
personality,
at least in so far it has.
The concern is to further the
development of personality,
which is a concern that's associated
with the desire for mental health or
subjective wellbeing,
which is a term I really don't like.
'Em or meaning.
It's not clear that those can be
strictly scientific pursuits.
So then if they're not strictly
scientific pursuits,
what what should you do about
understanding them?
If you look at studies after studies,
the problem with that is you get a very
narrow slice of the domain and it's
often not very comprehensible because in
order to understand the results of a
study,
you have to have the knowledge,
the underlying knowledge that's
necessary to put the study in some sort
of framework.
No,
that framework is going to be developed
by studying the relevance scientific
literature in psychological literature,
but behind that the framework has to be
expanded to include the relevant
philosophical assumptions
and I don't really think that you can
understand the details without
understanding the assumptions.
I,
I also think you're relegated to
memorization if you don't understand the
fundamentals and memorization has very
little to do with knowledge.
I mean you might be able to memorize
procedures that would enable you to act
on something like perhaps to fix an
automobile here or to repair or to play
a piece on the piano and it's not like
those things are not worth doing,
but
for these ideas to take root and have
effected meaning,
you have to understand them at the right
level of analysis.
And one of the things I really like
about personality theory,
especially the clinical end of it,
although not exclusively the clinical
end of it,
is that the people who were conducting
clinical practice and writing clinical
theory during the 20th century were in
fact dealing with the most profound
problems that affect people.
I mean,
I started my academic career as a
political scientist.
Well in so far as your,
any sort of political scientist when
you're an undergraduate.
I was not interested in it at all by my
third year because what I found was that
at least at this time,
and I don't know how much it's changed,
the political science,
scientists had already
decided that people were basically
motivated by economic concerns.
And to me that just was no use at all
because I wanted to know why they were
motivated by economic concerns.
So
it's easy to understand people in some
sense if you already decide what they
value,
but if you can't figure out what they
value or what they should value,
that's a whole different issue.
And that psychology,
it's an.
And it's a deep question because it
isn't even obvious whether the question
are there things you should value is a
reasonable question or that it can be
reasonably answered thing.
I can tell you about that.
That's most closely allied with my own
experience.
I don't mean personal experience,
but say experience as a clinician is
that aimless people are in real trouble
now.
I don't necessarily know why that is and
I don't necessarily know what that means
for what your aim should be,
but I've certainly seen for example,
like if you had to make a choice,
which all of you will in the next five
years or so between pursuing something
like diligently and establishing a fixed
identity because of that or remaining
bereft of choice and drifting.
I,
I can tell you that if you drift by the
time you're 30,
you're going to be one miserable person.
Now,
I'm not sure why that is exactly and I'm
not exactly sure that that necessarily
means that picking something and
sticking to it,
which is a form of apprenticeship is
better than drifting.
It depends on what you mean by better,
but I can tell you that not catalyzing
an identity seems to be a mistake and
it's a fatal mistake by the time you're
40.
It's very,
very difficult to recover from it at
that point because you're not young
anymore at that point and if you try to
catalyze an identity at that time,
which sometimes can happen,
you're competing with all these like
young,
shiny people and it's not who are much
more full of potential from the
perspective of an employer for example,
than you are.
It gets pretty dismal.
Anyways,
today we're going to go deeper into
philosophical presuppositions that we
have in the past and
I want to familiarize you with what I
think are the great philosophical and
psychological movements of the 20th
century because they.
They shape you and they shaped the world
you live in in,
in ways that are.
They're incalculable and if you don't
understand them,
you don't really know where you are.
You don't know where you are in history
and you don't know what ideas you're
possessed by.
No,
I think I told you when we were studying
that young said that people don't have
ideas that ideas have people which I
believe to be true.
One of young's lasting contributions in
some sense was that you should know what
ideas possess you because otherwise you
won't know what the hell they're doing
with you and when you think about all
the irrational and apparently
counterproductive things that people do
as individuals and also in a mass.
You have to ask yourself if you want to
be caught up in that sort of thing.
If you could be free from it.
If you are caught up in it just exactly
where is it that you're headed,
which was also something that you
thought you should figure out in case
where you were headed was not
necessarily where you would go if you
were making a fully informed conscious
where you would like to go.
If you're making a fully informed
conscious choice,
and I think the material that we're
dealing with in the next two lectures is
is the most relevant of all of the
material we're going to cover with
regards to the possession of people by
ideas.
The existentialists
who are tightly aligned philosophically
with the phenomenologists basically
emerged as a psychological movement
after World War II and there were
reasons for this.
I mean one of the reasons was that it
was quite obvious not only that World
War Two was an ideological battle
fundamentally between fascism and
western democracy,
roughly speaking,
and it was immediately supplanted by
another ideological battle which was the
one between communism and liberalism,
roughly speaking,
and so the issue of ideological
possession
and the and the relationship between the
individual whose ideologically possessed
and their responsibility and the actions
of the state became paramount concerns
in the 19 fifties as they should have.
You know,
because one of the last questions that
that remained after World War Two that
still has been insufficiently answered
is when the mask goes insane.
What is the culpability of the
individuals who compose the mass?
Now you can circumvent that question,
say with regards to what happened in
Nazi Germany by assuming that it was top
down coercion that turned the massive
ordinary German citizens into majority
Nazis,
but I don't think that there's any
evidence that those sorts of ideas are
true.
There is research bearing on people's
willingness to conform to authority
figures and that is somewhat wral.
You know the famous experiments,
the prison experiment,
for example,
at Stanford,
where undergraduates were divided
arbitrarily and two guards and
prisoners,
and then they ran a simulation of a
prison.
Then of course the guards turned into
sadistic psychopaths and the some of
them did anyways,
and the prisoners turned into like
cringing victims in no time flat.
You know,
there.
There's obviously an element there that
that demonstrates that people are very
responsive to situational cues and that
that can go out of hand very rapidly,
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
you can use
your tendency to be
accommodating to authority or the human
tendency to be accommodating to
authority as an explanation for the rise
of mass movements say like Nazi as Imr
or communism because it doesn't really
help.
The explanation doesn't really help.
It's like,
okay,
well,
fair enough.
Some people in the mass were mere
followers.
What about the leaders?
Well,
maybe they're all followers right up to
say Hitler,
so it's Hitler's fault.
It's all Hitler's fault.
It's like,
well,
you're elevating the guy to the status
of a god at that point,
you know now and evil,
God,
but still,
if he's got all the motive power,
he's basically,
you can't.
You can't separate him from the idea of
Lucifer,
you know,
he's become an archetypal figure of evil
at that point,
and it's the same with Stalin and Mao.
I mean,
no though,
those,
they were very,
very bad men.
There's no doubt about it.
But to localize all the evil in them and
to consider everyone else victimized
followers is,
it's a convenient idea,
but it's not helpful.
Now that makes all the fault.
That just makes the followers pathetic
for a different reason.
You know,
they're not actively self engaged in
cruelty for their own purposes apart
from conformity,
but they're just as pathetic and evil as
they would be if they were doing it on
their own volition.
I don't see the difference between a
bully and bullies,
henchmen.
In fact,
I think the bully probably has more
encouraged than the henchman,
you know,
it's courage of a fairly peculiar sort.
But
so the existentialists,
this is what they were concerned about,
you know,
and the,
the locus of their concern was basically
it was basically Nicha
and you all know that
the reason I concentrate on nature and
also on Dostoevsky is because I think
those two people summed up the 19th
century.
I really think that and that the
problems that they laid out
and predicted would unfold in the 20th
century were the problems that unfolded
in the 20th century.
So they got their predictions right and
I think they got their causality right
to and given the inability of social
scientists,
including psychologists to predict large
term mass events.
The fact that these two people managed
at 30 to 40 years before the events
unfolded,
didn't even longer than that.
Seems to me that it's pretty much
worthwhile to consider them
psychologists.
And uh,
certainly Nisha thought that of himself
and so to Dostoevsky for that matter.
And they had immense influence on people
like Freud and jung and Rogers.
All the people that we'd been studying.
Their thinking is,
is lying underneath every issue we've
discussed.
This is,
this is niches.
One of nature's great statements.
Okay,
what is great?
One must either be silent or speak with
greatness,
with greatness.
That means cynically in with innocence.
What I relate is the history of the next
two centuries.
I described what is coming,
what can no longer come differently?
The advent of nihilism,
our whole European culture is moving
from some time now with a tortured
tension that is growing from decade to
decade as towards the catastrophe
restlessly violently headlong like a
river that wants to reach the end that
no longer reflects,
that's afraid to reflect.
He that speaks here has conversely done
nothing so far,
but to reflect as a philosopher and
solitary by instinct who has found his
advantage in standing,
aside outside,
why has the advent of nihilism become
necessary?
Because the values we have had hitherto
thus draw their final consequence.
Because Nihilism represents the ultimate
logical extension of our great values
and ideals.
Because we must experience nihilism
because before we can find out what
value these values really had.
So one of nature's claims,
for example,
was that
as Christianity in Europe transformed
itself into science,
he felt that that one of the advantage
to the Catholic domination of Europe for
so many centuries was that
the mind of the Catholic adherence who
took the discipline seriously or the
dogmas seriously learn to interpret all
events under the under the Schema of a
single theory,
and he thought about that as a form of
discipline.
So you could imagine.
Imagine that if I,
if I want to teach you how to theorize,
I might teach you a theory and have you
adopted
and niches point would mean be that
well,
that means you know a theory,
but it also means something else.
It also means that now you know how to
theorize and the important consequence
of learning a theory may not be the
theory.
It may be that you've learned to fear
rocks.
Now,
nature also pointed out that once you
learn to theorize,
you can separate yourself from the.
From the theory that gave rise to that
knowledge.
And so you can start to theorize even
about the theory that you mastered,
and he thought that's what happened to
Europe as a consequence of its
domination by Christianity,
especially because of Christianity is
essential insistence on the utility of
the truth.
Now he thought that was transformed
after Catholicism into scientific
investigation,
but that the spirit of theorizing and
truth remained intact,
and then that the consequence of that
was that the European mind was
disciplined by a dogma.
Then it freed itself from the dogma.
Then it turned its power on the Dogma
and noted that the dogmas itself seemed
to be grounded in nothing.
That you could get a grip on,
the way you grip things with an
empirical mind,
and so it fell apart.
You know,
and that's not saying much more than
science posed a fatal challenge to
religion,
but it's saying it in a much more
profound and interesting way.
And it also explains why he makes this
claim,
that nihilism is the logical conclusion
of the great values and ideals.
So he didn't think about nihilism as a
counter proposition.
Say too dogmatic Christianity.
He thought about it as the logical
outcome of that,
so now you think,
well,
is that relevant?
Why is that relevant?
Well,
I think it's relevant for a lot of ideas
are for a lot of reasons.
The first question is are the first
observation might be that a tremendous
amount of mental illness,
and this is an existential claim,
is grounded in nihilism.
When someone who's depressed comes to
see you,
what they often say is,
I can't see any point in life and that
isn't what they mean.
What they mean is they see the meaning
of life as suffering,
which is a meaning,
right?
It's and that that's not bearable,
and then the question is,
given that,
why bother with it?
And that's the fundamental question of
suicide,
and it's a philosophical question.
I think it was [inaudible] who said that
the only real philosophical question was
whether or not to commit suicide.
Now you know,
that's a little dark.
I mean,
he might get,
maybe it will come in,
we could have used some Ssri,
but you get the point and it's,
it's,
it's inappropriate in my estimation,
to even discuss something,
even to discuss depression with someone
who's depressed,
especially if they're intelligent and
open and therefore more tilted towards
philosophical wonderings without
actually addressing the issue.
Why live in the face of suffering?
Okay,
so that's one problem.
It's to the degree that you will find it
difficult in your life to build anything
solid under your feet that you can stand
on and and believe,
have faith in.
Let's say you're going to be adrift and
the reason for that is a lot of the
things you're going to have to do will
be difficult and they'll involve
suffering,
which is also an existential claim.
So the existentialists for example,
they don't make the same claim Freud
does.
Freud claims that
in some sense that the normal person is
mentally healthy apart from the mild
distress of normal life,
and then in order to be
psychopathological you have to have been
hurt
and maybe multiple times or there's
other things that could contribute to
that,
but the existentialists would say,
no,
let's.
Let's just wait a minute here.
Maybe the fundamental condition of human
beings is nihilism and suffering and
that something has to be produced to
counter that in order for life to be
tolerable.
Well,
that I think that's a perfectly
reasonable proposition.
Now it's a strange proposition because
I've seen in my lifetime I've seen
people who are tormented by existential
ideas who can't get them out of their
mind.
You know,
ideas that relate to the meaning of life
and then other people and and concerned
about death,
for example,
in the extinguishing of everything that
seems to have any value.
It's our primary concern with them and
then I've seen other people for whom
those questions never seem to arise.
Now I think those people are,
first of all,
I think they're conservative people.
I don't think they're very open and I
think they're probably rather low in
neuroticism,
so they're not philosophically curious.
They don't go up chains of abstractions
and even if they do,
they don't necessarily get disturbed in
the most profound areas of there being
by the questioning,
but that still leaves plenty of people
in the other category.
Now,
the nihilism.
Well,
you know there's naturalism and atheism
or closely related.
I don't think they're identical by any
stretch of the imagination,
although I think it's difficult for
atheism to describe why it's not
essentially nihilistic and that's
Dostoevsky's big criticism because
Dostoyevsky's claim was that without any
fundamental value assumed,
then there's no reason why you can't do
anything you want and that's his famous
line.
If there is no god,
then everything is permitted and all of
Dostoyevsky's novel writing is an
exploration of that idea and sometimes
it's an exploration of what that idea
might mean if it was acted out in the
life of a given individual.
And so that would be say crime and
punishment and another would be say in
his book,
the devil's are the possessed.
It's unreal.
It's a.
it's a,
it's an examination of what that idea
means if it's gripped by an individual
who has social and political ambitions,
and that's when Dostoevsky basically
prophesied,
so to speak,
that one of the consequences of the
death of God would be the rise basically
of communist totalitarianism because
essentially that's what he predicted in
the devils,
so that's pretty dead on accurate
prediction.
It was really quite stunning to me when
I came across it.
Injury made exactly the same prediction
by the way,
and so for those two men,
the the death of an ultimate meaning
system,
especially one that you can see when you
think about something like European
Christianity.
It's misleading in some sense because
the system of beliefs that that
constituted European Christianity and
other great belief systems wasn't 2000
years old was like 25,000 years old.
You know,
you.
You can think about a desk beginning at
year zero,
but it's a mistake.
It's a mistake from a historical
perspective.
The idea is that that,
that profound religious traditions are
predicated on are generally grounded in
ideas that are much,
much older than the traditions
themselves.
And so in some sense,
when at the end of the 19th century when
things fell apart for us and we can no
longer rely on our,
our history,
predicated morality to guide us,
it wasn't merely that we lost an
overlay,
a psychological overlay that had been
laid on humanity for 2000 years.
It was way deeper than that.
We don't even know how long those,
how old those ideas are.
We knew we have some idea about how old
they are.
They're at least as old as written
culture.
But we also know that the people that
who have been brought into the
mainstreams of history,
you know,
as the world has united,
the people who are not literate had
mythologies that drew from the same
themes in some of those people as far as
we can tell,
had lived a lifestyle that was
essentially unchanged for 25,000 years.
And so the Australian aborigines are
like that.
So there's plenty of evidence that the
idea is these ideas are extraordinarily
old.
And what that means is that when we
separate from them,
in some sense,
not only do we separate from our
philosophical presuppositions,
but we separate from the historical
consequences of our biology.
It's a serious problem.
And I think that's partly why it's very
difficult to distinguish between someone
who's nihilistic and someone who's
mentally ill.
That's not a radical claim.
I mean people especially who are on the
depressed side of the distribution will
will tell you that they're nihilistic.
You know,
they may not use that terminology,
although they often do.
I just can't see any point.
So like,
well why does that matter?
Why?
Why does it matter?
It seems to be a fact that it matters.
So it's an interesting fact.
That's a phenomenal logical fact in some
sense,
because one of the things that heidegger
pointed out and he was a founder of the
phenomenological school,
was that the,
the,
your primary orientation to the world.
He thinks in a strange way that your
primary orientation to the world was one
of care.
So you could say,
well,
what characterizes your experience?
What sort of creature ru and heidegger's
answer would be?
Well,
you're a creature who cares about things
in so far as you're engaged in the
world,
your primary orientation is one of care
and you can think about that as a value,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's a consequence of your value
orientation and God only knows where
that comes from.
Part of its biological part of is
developmental,
part of it's historical.
It's very,
very complex,
but if you stopped caring about
everything,
you're in trouble and that that's one of
the things that seems to indicate that
caring is actually a fundamental
reality.
You start caring about things.
You don't stop suffering and it seems
that unless the caring counterbalances
the suffering,
you can't maintain an even keel and
that's partly because it doesn't seem
just right.
I mean when terrible things happen to
people,
they always say,
well,
two things.
How is it that being could be
constituted in this manner?
Like what the Hell's going at?
The fundamental levels of reality that
such suffering has to be the case.
You'll certainly ask that if you have a
child who's diagnosed with cancer for
example,
or you might think,
well,
why is this cruelty?
As it appears necessarily aimed at me
right now in this place,
when hypothetically it could have not
happened at all or perhaps being visited
on someone more deserving,
you know,
which is the good remain,
the gooder punished to the evil remain
unpunished,
something like that,
so that that produces for human beings
that produces a cry of
of of a cry for justice.
How?
How can the world be constituted that
way and that seems to be built into us.
Those aren't questions we can just
avoid.
There are questions that will arise in
your psyche.
They'll arise this fundamental questions
when when sufficiently terrible things
happened to you,
so the existentialists would say,
well,
those are conditions of existence.
You're just stuck with that.
It's part of it's part of human nature.
It's part of human being to to be
perplexed by those questions.
Then the question is,
at least in part,
is there any way of answering them?
You said,
we require it some time.
New Values.
Nihilism stands at the door.
Whence comes this uncanny as to all
guests
point of departure.
It is an error to consider social
distress or physiological degeneration
or corruption of all things as the cause
of nihilism.
Now,
that's a typical night Nietzschean
phrase because there are three profound
ideas in that sentence and each one is
in a different phrase.
So neat.
You said at one point I can write in a
sentence what other people write in a
book,
and then he said,
well,
what other people can't even write in a
book,
and this sentence is a good example of
that.
So what does he say?
Well,
you know,
if you see that people are suffering and
in trouble,
one thing you can say that is that the
reason for that is that the economic
system is unjust and they're layered
along the bottom and that's the
fundamental cause of their suffering,
but nature doesn't allow that to be an
interpretation,
a causal interpretation,
because he says there are multiple ways
of interpreting your position and mere
absence of material.
Luxury does not necessarily destined you
to one perspective or another
physiological degeneration.
While people are unhappy or suffering
because they're ill in some manner where
how you could make that a matter of
definition by saying that if you're
suffering or unhappy you are ill,
but that's not a causal argument.
It's just a different way of
categorizing the data and neat you would
reject that because he would also note
that there's some correlation between
physiological health and meaning in
life,
but the correlation is the correlation
doesn't imply causality and and even if
it did,
the relationship is by no means perfect
to the that you would want a
relationship to be before you accepted
it as relevant or corruption of all
things.
While that would be the idea that being
itself is evil,
like an evil trick,
which is what tolstoy said.
By the way,
when he wrote his confessions,
because tall story at the height of his
intellectual power,
he was the most famous novelist in the
world and unbelievably well regarded
while throughout the world,
but particularly in Russia and he was a
very like socially benevolent man and
well regarded for his wisdom.
For years.
He was afraid to go outside with a rope
or a gun because he thought he would
either hang or shoot himself.
And the reason for that was that he had
been struck by the idea that life is so
unbearable that it should be eradicated.
And he couldn't think his way out of
that.
And it was,
uh,
it was,
it was a,
a form of thought that was actually very
characteristic of intellectuals in
Russia during his time,
in,
during his time,
in his place.
I mean,
Dostoevsky wrote about exactly the same
sorts of things,
but it,
even tolstoy noted that merely observing
that the world was a corrupt and evil
place was not necessarily enough to tell
people towards nihilism because there
seemed to be people who weren't
nihilistic despite the fact that that
seems self evident to him.
And he thought tolstoy actually turned
to the Russian people.
You know,
he,
he was very entranced by the idea of the
folk and folk wisdom.
And he turned to the Russian people as a
source of new inspiration.
Like the peasantry and tolstoy actually
fought for the freedom of the peasantry
and he felt that there are simple faith,
so to speak,
was something truly admirable rather
than something pathetically pathetic and
weak from an intellectual perspective.
He strove to emulate that.
That criticism lists faith,
but of course he couldn't do it because
once you've taken a bite out of the
apple,
there's no going back,
so to speak.
Need just says distress,
whether psychic,
physical or intellectual need not at all
produced nihilism.
That is the radical rejection of value,
meaning and desirability.
Such distress always permits a variety
of interpretations.
Rather it is one particular
interpretation.
The Christian world,
one,
that nihilism is rooted the end of
Christianity at the hands of its own
morality which cannot be replaced,
which turns against the Christian God.
The sense of truthfulness,
highly developed by Christianity is
nauseated by the falseness and
mendacious snus of all Christian
interpretations of the world and of
history.
It's a rebound from God is the truth to
the equally fanatical faith.
All his false and active Buddhism
skepticism regarding morality is what is
decisive.
The end of the moral interpretation of
the world,
which no longer has any sanction after
just tried to escape into some beyond
leads to nihilism,
all lacks meaning well,
that's rooted niches,
criticism of Christianity,
because he believed that Christianity
was exceptionally morally flawed because
all it offered its followers was the
possibility of salvation and redemption
from their suffering after they were
dead,
so it was projected into some other
world which as far as nature is
concerned,
alleviated people have their local
responsibility to try to improve things
here and now and use comments about that
were essentially that it was the pro
scientists recognition of the fact that
the spiritual salvation that
Christianity promised was no longer
sufficient.
That motivated the development of
science.
So for the,
for the,
for the early Christians,
this is part of the tension between
Christianity and science.
For the early Christians,
the idea was that the earth in some
sense was inner radical bleak,
corrupt,
and that all you could hope for in your
earthly life was suffering and that you
should.
You should accept your suffering and
hope for salvation in the future after
you're dead.
Well,
obviously that philosophy seat appeared
insufficient for people and Young's
hypothesis about the development of
science was that a counter fantasy
developed in the unconscious of the
Europeans,
which was that the material realm which
had been defined as evil and therefor
not worthy of any study or any pursuit
whatsoever actually held the seeds of
the redemption that was lacking,
and so that was young's commentary on
the idea of the philosopher stone
because the alchemist who are who were
pro scientists were trying to trying to
find a material substance that would be
the philosopher's stone that would offer
it's holders wealth,
health and eternal life,
and so you think,
well,
why are we pursuing science?
Well,
hopefully,
because we think it'll do some good here
and now right in our bodies,
and so you regarded science itself as
stemming from that compensate story,
dream.
Brilliant idea.
It's actually the only idea I've ever
read that that seems to do a reasonable
psychological account for the emergence
of science as a discipline is a very
strange practice.
You know,
you have to.
You have to narrow your interests
tremendously.
To be a scientist,
you have to focus on one set of
phenomena you know that might appear as
useless to contemplate is how many
angels can dance on the head of a pin.
You have to devote decades to the study
of that thing to make incremental
process or progress.
Why in the world would people ever be
motivated to do that?
Well,
young interpretation was well.
There was a deep counter movement
towards the over spiritualization of the
psyche and that was the revaluation of
matter and its possibilities.
While Nisha believe that Christianity as
it,
as it stood at the end of the 18
hundreds,
was an untenable philosophy because he
thought it had abandoned moral
obligations by escaping into some beyond
and therefore damned life as it was
actually lived by human big.
So he felt that the device was a good
thing.
He he points out one other thing,
and this is the difference between
having a theory and then learning to
theorize.
It says,
look,
if you've been raised in a tradition,
whatever that tradition happens to be,
you have a belief system.
Whatever that belief system happens to
be and it falls apart on you at any one
point,
you suffer for two reasons.
The first is your belief system fell
apart and that's not a good thing.
It leaves everything unfixed and open
and you drown in possibility.
In a sense that's a character guardian
phrase,
but the second consequences,
even worse,
once you've learned that one belief
system that's solid could be demolished
and fall apart,
then it's very difficult ever again,
to have any faith in any belief systems
whatsoever.
So not only do you become a doubter of
your own creed,
let's say you become a metadata which is
the doubter of all belief systems.
While in the step from that to nihilism,
maybe those are exactly the same thing.
You know,
and that's really,
you could think about that in some sense
as the disease of the critical rational
mind.
It can saw off any branch that it's
sitting on and you know,
the utility of that is leave no stone
unturned,
right?
You're supposed to question things and
the utility of that is you learn new
things,
but the price you paid for it is that
you're not necessarily ever certain
about anything and you know,
you could say,
well,
maybe you shouldn't be certain about
anything,
but you know you can forget that you
know you're.
You're going to have to act as if you're
certain many times in your life for when
you choose a permanent mate for,
for example,
if you do that,
which you probably will because your
university educated and university
educated people still do that,
although no one else does so,
and you're going to pick a career and
you're going to.
You're going to make decisions one after
the other about which if you're not
certain you can't make,
in which case you have no life.
You're just a whirlwind of chaos.
So you're stuck with the necessity of
following a course of action which is
acted out certainty that your intellect
can not regard as appropriate and that's
hard on people.
Why should I choose this instead of
this?
Why should I act this way instead of
that way?
You know?
I don't know is not a very useful answer
when you're a creature that's is
cognitively able as we are.
This is a brilliant.
This is an absolute.
This is something absolutely brilliant.
It's very difficult for me to believe
that it was written
so long ago.
So this is Dostoyevsky's criticism of
communism.
Forty years before communism was a
political force,
so Dostoevsky's thinking really hard
about this nihilism problem.
By the way,
nature read Dostoevsky extensively.
He's thinking about,
he thinks,
well,
there seems to be two alternatives.
One is this superhuman nihilism,
which is sort of a variant of what needs
you propose because nature proposed that
it would become the responsibility of
every human being after the death of
their religious tradition to establish
their own values.
Now you think that's it?
He didn't think people could do it.
He thought there'd have to be a new kind
of person who could manage it because
you know he's basically asking you to
generate a coherent and pragmatically
applicable philosophical structure out
of nothing during your lifetime.
It's like,
well,
good luck with that.
You know?
Plus,
he also assumed that people create
values or that they could create values
and you know that's true to some degree,
and we'll talk about this more when we
get into the phenomenal logical end of
things,
but it's not self evident,
right?
Because one of the things you may notice
is that you can't force yourself to love
someone,
right?
You can't just decide that you're going
to value someone.
Then poof,
that happens.
In fact,
you may want with all your heart as far
or at least with all your mind to value
someone because they deserve it.
They've never mistreated you.
Maybe you've said you'd be loyal to them
and poof,
someone comes along.
You're tremendously attracted to them
and off you go.
Like,
like someone who's possessed.
Well,
did you create that value?
It's like,
well it didn't closer to your own
experience.
Like can you actually make yourself
interested in something your board
about?
It's like good luck trying that,
you know,
you'd rather clean up underneath your
bed than read a paper you don't want to
read.
You know,
when you can't just tell yourself,
well,
I need to read this paper for the
following reasons,
and Poof,
it becomes interesting.
It's like,
no,
no.
Your value systems,
whatever they happen to be,
you're off doing their own thing and the
reason for that in large part is because
they're possessed by ideas that you
don't know about that have these
historical roots and that play you in
some sense like they play puppets and
this stuff is no joke.
Okay,
so this is what Dostoevsky said way back
in the late 18 hundreds.
This was in a book called a
notes from underground and it's about a
man who's like hamlet in some sense.
He's a modern man.
He's,
he's a 20th century man really.
And his problem is he's hyper
intelligent and he can't figure out what
the hell he should do with his life.
And it's really bothering him and it's
worse than that because not only is it
really bothering him that he can't get
his act together and act with any degree
of,
of consistency and character,
but he knows that he can't do that.
And he tortures himself about his
weakness at the same time,
so he's a very neurotic character,
but he's a sophisticated and intelligent
neurotic.
And so he's run through all the
arguments that you might conjure up to
sort of talk yourself out of being
neurotic and suffering.
He has nothing but contempt for his own
character.
He thinks he's much weaker than people
who can just act without thinking.
And he's,
he's in this pip,
this horrible pit,
and it's a lot.
It's a wonderful thing to read.
It's quite blockly comical.
And it's a great philosophical and
psychological study.
Anyways,
and one of the sections of this book,
niches or Dostoevsky's protagonist
starts to talk about alternatives to his
nihilistic,
hopelessness.
And he thinks about utopianism as a
potential alternative.
So what's the utopianism?
Well,
in some sense,
medieval Christianity promised people
redemption after they died,
while the Utopian creed does the same
thing,
except it promises it here and now.
So that's communism was a particular
utopian.
Crete and fascism had the same element.
Although it was,
it was,
it was.
I don't know how to describe it.
It was less intellectually sophisticated
than communism.
Communism is basically said,
look,
if you guys just stop being selfish and
share,
we can transform the world into a place
where everyone will have enough of
everything and everyone will be able to
do what they want to do and because of
the natural goodness of people,
if,
if selfishness can be overcome,
that'll be the next best thing to a
paradise.
It's like it was powerful.
It was a powerful idea for people.
You know,
80 years of our history was spent
assessing and battling out the validity
of that idea and hundreds of millions of
people died as a consequence of it.
And you can understand why it was so
attractive.
I mean,
still utopian ideologies are attractive
to people.
I mean,
it's,
it's hard to read radical Islam is
anything other than a Utopian ideology.
You know,
the idea is once you establish rigid
sharia,
then poof,
you know,
you've got the Kingdom of God on earth.
Well,
and part of the reason that the radical
Muslims are fighting against the West is
because they see what they're doing as a
counter position to western nihilism.
And it's partly because they don't want
to fall into that,
you know,
we would say,
well that's progress.
It's like,
yeah,
it's progress by our standards and it
comes at a price.
And also we don't even understand how it
was that we paid the price.
So the reason I'm telling you this is
because you don't want to be thinking
for any time at all that these sorts of
issues have disappeared or that they're
not relevant.
They're relevant now.
The guy who's advising potent,
his name is Alexander do and he's no
admirer of Western liberalism,
he thinks about it as fundamentally
nihilistic.
He thinks that it's universal
application would result in the
disillusion of all local culture and the
production of this sort of
materialistic,
hyper individuality.
And he's an admirer of tradition,
you know,
and specifically Russian Orthodox
tradition.
And he believes that the cult cultures,
India,
Russia,
and China in particular,
should develop their own local cultures.
Keep the West the hell out and act as a
counter position to nihilistic
liberalism.
Now you know,
you can say what you want about that.
I think [inaudible] biggest problem is
that,
you know,
he doesn't want that diverse ideas that
characterize the west to bump up against
Russia and dissolve it,
but what he fails to understand is those
same ideas are going to emerge within
Russia anyways and if you know,
if you want to keep them away outside,
you have to keep them away inside.
And the Soviets already tried that for
70 years with pretty dire results.
So I don't think he can get around the
problem merely by,
you know,
putting up walls,
but,
but he's going to try and that's what
Putin is doing.
So these ideas haven't disappeared at
all.
Like they're there.
They underlie all of the great conflicts
that characterize the modern age.
Now,
Dostoevsky criticized utopianism and
it's brilliant his,
his formulation.
So I'm going to read it to you in short.
One may say anything about the history
of the world,
anything that might enter the most
disordered imagination.
The only thing one can't say is that
it's rational.
The very word sticks in one's throat.
And indeed this is the odd thing that is
continually happening.
There are continually turning up in
life,
moral and rational persons,
sages and lovers of humanity who may get
their object to live all their lives as
morally and rationally as possible,
to be so,
to speak,
a light to their neighbors simply in
order to show them that it is possible
to live morally and rationally in this
world,
and yet we all know that these very
people sooner or later have been false
to themselves playing some queer trick,
often most unseemly one.
Now I asked you what can be expected of
man,
since he is a being endowed with such
strange qualities,
shower upon him,
every earthly blessing,
drowning in a sea of happiness so that
nothing but bubbles of bliss can be seen
on the surface.
Give them economic prosperity,
such that he should have nothing else to
do,
but sleep,
eat cakes and busy himself with the
continuation of his species and even
then out of sheer and gratitude,
sheer spite,
man would play you some nasty trick.
He would even.
Risk is cakes and with deliberately
desire the most fatal rubbish,
the most uneconomical absurdity,
simply to introduce into all this
positive,
good sense,
his fatal,
fantastic element.
It's just as fantastic dreams is vulgar,
folly that he will desire to retain
simply in order to prove to himself as
though that were so necessary that men
still are men and not the keys of a
piano,
which the laws of nature threatened to
control completely so completely that
one will be able to desire nothing but
by the calendar,
so clearly that's Dostoyevsky's
criticism of materialistic determinism,
right,
which he felt as a spiritual threat.
Fundamentally,
it's proposition being that animals and
human beings,
we're deterministic machines.
It's a Newtonian worldview and that
because of that,
everything could be calculated and
planned ahead of time because it could
be predicted and measured,
and that is not all.
Even if men really were nothing but a
piano key.
Even if this were proved to him by
natural science and mathematics,
even then he would not become reasonable
but would purposely do something
perverse out of simple in gratitude
simply to gain his point.
And if he does not find means he will
contrive destruction and chaos,
sufferings of all sorts,
only to gain his point.
He'll launch a curse upon the world and
as the only man can curse.
It's this privilege and the primary
distinction between him and other
animals,
maybe by his curse alone he will attain
is object and convinced himself that
he's a man and not a piano key.
If you say that all this too can be
calculated and tabulated chaos and
darkness and curses so that the mere
possibility of calculating it all
beforehand would stop.
It all and reason would reassert itself.
That man would purposely go mad in order
to be rid of reason and gain his point.
I believe in it.
I answer for it.
For the whole work of man really seems
to consist of nothing but proving to
himself every minute that he's a man and
not a piano key.
It may be at the cost of his skin,
it might be by cannibalism
and this being sold.
Can one help being tempted to rejoice
that it has not yet come off and the
desire still depends on something we
don't know you will scream at me.
That is if you condescend to do so,
that no one's touching my freewill,
that all they're concerned with is that
my will should have,
should have itself of its own freewill,
coincide with my own normal interests,
with the laws of nature and arithmetic.
Good Evans.
Gentlemen,
what sort of free will is left when we
come to tabulation and arithmetic when
it will all be a case of twice two,
makes four,
twice.
Two makes four without my will as a
freewill meant that.
So what's his point?
Well,
it's sort of a garden of eden point.
You know,
what are people like magine?
You could reconstruct a paradise on
earth.
You know,
hypothetically,
that's what everyone wants.
We could go live in the paradise and
that would be the end of the problem
we'd all live happily ever after.
But in the original paradise story,
that's what people were provided with.
And the first thing they did when they
were put there was to do the one thing
that they were told not to do that would
bring it all crashing down and that was
immediately what they did.
And so Dostoevsky story's actually a
retelling of that idea.
The idea was that that people aren't
like the utopians think,
we don't want it easy,
we don't want it comfortable,
we don't want to good.
And the reason for that is we'd be bored
stiff and so the defendant,
nobody ever did put us in the kind of
nursery that would require us never to
exert any effort to do anything at all
whatsoever ever again.
Even if it meant going insane,
we destroy it.
And then he takes that further.
He says.
And that's a good thing.
Kierkegaard writing earlier about 40
years earlier said something quite
similar.
It is now about four years ago that I
got the notion of wanting to try my luck
as an author.
I remember it quite clearly.
It was on a Sunday.
Yes,
that's it.
A Sunday afternoon.
I was seated as usual out of doors at
the cafe in the Fredericksburg Garden.
I had been a student for half a score of
years,
although never lazy.
All my activity nevertheless was like a
glittering inactivity,
a kind of occupation for which I still
have a great partiality and for which
perhaps are even have a little genius.
I read much spent the remainder of the
day idling and thinking or thinking an
idling,
but that was all it came to.
So there I sat and smoke my cigar until
I lapsed into thought among other
thoughts.
I remember these you are going on.
I said to myself to become an old man
without being anything and really
without undertaking to do anything.
On the other hand,
wherever you look about you and
literature and in life,
you see the celebrated names and
figures,
the precious and much heralded men who
were coming into prominence and are much
talked about,
the many benefactors of the age who knew
how to benefit mankind by making life
easier and easier.
Some by railways,
others by omnibuses and steamboats,
others by the telegraph,
others by easily apprehended compendiums
and short recitals of everything worth
knowing
and finding the true benefactors of the
age who makes spiritual existence in
virtue of thought easier and easier,
yet more and more significant,
and what are you doing here?
My soliloquy was interrupted
for a cigar with smoked out and a new
one had to be lit so I smoked again,
and then suddenly this thought flashed
through my mind,
you must do something,
but in as much as with your limited
capacities,
it will be impossible to make anything
easier than it has become.
You must with the same humanitarian
enthusiasm as the others undertake to
make something harder.
This notion pleased me immensely and at
the same time,
it flattered me to think that I liked
the rest of them would be loved in the
steam by the whole community,
for when all combined in every way to
make everything easier,
there remains only one possible danger,
namely that the eas becomes so great
that it becomes all together.
Two,
great.
Then there's only one want left though
it is not yet felt want,
when people will want difficulty out of
love for mankind and out of despair at
my embarrassing situation,
seeing that I had accomplished nothing
and was unable to make anything easier
than it has already been made and moved
by a genuine interest in those who make
everything easy.
I can save it as my task to create
difficulties everywhere.
Now,
one of the things you might ask yourself
is
sometimes you come to university and
people talk about happiness.
For example,
you talk about positive psychology.
I'm not a fan of positive psychology by
the way because happiness is basically
extroversion minus neuroticism,
and we knew that 15 years ago,
so we didn't need to make a lot of noise
about it.
So anyways,
one of the things you might ask yourself
is,
well,
why did you come to university?
Did you actually come to university to
make yourself happier?
Well,
let's think about that for a minute.
Here's one thing to think about.
We know if that if you put animals in a
relatively boring situation like rats in
a boarding situation and you give them
free access to cocaine,
they'll just take cocaine until they're
dead basically.
Now it wraps in the normal environment.
Won't do that,
but board rats that are sort of isolated
cocaine's really an excellent thing as
far as they're concerned.
They'll ignore sex.
They'll ignore food.
I think they'll still drink water if I
remember correctly,
but it's cocaine all the way and if you
could inject an electrode into their
minds,
their brains,
which people have done,
you can inject the electrode down into
the hypothalamus,
into the part that's associated with the
reward centers.
It's the source of the dopaminergic
tracts and you can set them up so that
if the rat pushes a button,
they get a little jolt of of happiness
basically in the rattle.
Sit there and push that happiness button
in a rather frantic way as if it's
looking for something else in some
sense,
but it will certainly do it just because
it's a peculiar kind of reward.
Now the question might be,
would you allow yourself to be wired up
like that?
Now you might think there might be some
times in your life where you think that
might just be a perfectly fine idea,
but most of you,
I suppose I pursue,
wouldn't do that for a second,
for the same reasons perhaps that you
don't avail yourself of unlimited access
to cocaine,
which is a very a stimulant that's very
good at producing positive emotion.
It's a powerful psychomotor stimulants
and so it affects the parts of your
brain that are active when you're doing
something that you think is worthwhile
and productive,
so why not just do that all the time?
That's the question that Elvis Huxley's
brave new world.
Got Everything you want.
Take a drug to keep you calm and happy,
poof.
Perfect.
Well,
is that what you want?
And if the answer is no,
then you might ask yourself,
what the hell do you want?
Now,
one of the things I've thought a lot
about lately is lately being 10 years,
I suppose is there are these statutes
that I've seen,
I've looked at pictures of them online,
there,
statues of Atlas,
you know,
an atlas is this God who has the world
on his shoulders and that's his destiny
or is cursed,
is to have the world on his shoulders.
And he might say,
well,
you know,
poor atlas,
maybe just put the damn world down and
you know,
go out for a beer or something,
but,
but then you might also think,
well,
what is that figure trying to.
What is that?
That idea of trying to indicate because
it's an old idea.
It's a profound idea.
There's something divine about a figure
with the world on his shoulders.
Well,
I might say the real.
That's the reason you're in university.
Whether you know it or not.
You're here to take the world on your
shoulders because that's a sufficiently
profound and worthwhile exercise so that
all the suffering that you're going to
have might be regarded as worthwhile
because the value of what you're doing
is so high.
Because that's what you might ask,
is there something that you could do
whose value is so high that the fact for
the existentialists existentialists,
it's a fact that you're mortal and
vulnerable and prone to suffering
inescapably that you would find that not
only acceptable but desirable.
You'd say,
I'll pay that.
I paid that price.
Well,
that's an existential question.
You might say.
That's the existential question and one
of the things that's very interesting
about that question is,
I'm going to talk about this a lot.
Next class is what happens if you make
the opposite choice?
Well,
I think the 20th century actually showed
us what happened when people made the
opposite choice because as far as I can
tell,
when people abandoned their
divine responsibility,
let's say
to the Utopian claims of a totalitarian
state or too hopeless nihilism,
the consequences on the one hand with
nihilism was despair and illness and the
consequence on the totalitarian end of
things.
The Utopian end was that while you might
not die,
but you're certainly going to have a
hand in making sure that a lot of other
people do,
and so
I suppose it to some degree,
it depends on what you want for proof,
no proof with regards to what you should
do.
Now the conclusion I've drawn from all
this from reading the existentialist is
that
if it's the pointless suffering of
humanity and the inability to extract
meaning from that,
that makes you a nihilist and that
justifies it.
Let's say you're making a claim,
right?
The claim is
the implicit claim is that suffering is
bad and should be halted.
It's something like that and so maybe
you'll do that by becoming suicidal or
maybe you do that by becoming ultimately
genocidal,
which is also an option that's open to
more than a few people,
but there's a logical inconsistency in
that as far as I can tell,
which is that
your initial presupposition is that
suffering is actually bad.
It should be mitigated.
It should be.
It should be reduced.
It should perhaps even be eliminated.
Well,
if you pick up the cloak of nihilism or
maybe you pick up the cloak of
ideological totalitarianism,
then we know what the consequence of
that is,
the consequences that everything that's
already really bad becomes so much more
worse that it's almost unimaginable
and so even by the standards of the
gnarliest who says that the suffering of
being should result in its elimination,
the consequences of thinking that way or
a flipping to the other side and
adopting some sort of defensive
videology is that things go from being
merely the sort of bad state of the
earth as it is now to something as
hellish as the Soviet gulags are the
Russian concentration camps or miles.
Great experiment in the Cultural
Revolution which probably killed 100
million people know about,
which we generally hear nothing.
No.
You know,
one of the things the existentialists
would say is
what's the relationship between mental
health and responsibility?
And that.
That's a good question because it also
has to do something with something like
the definition of mental health and
responsibility.
It's like
if you want your life to be well
constituted,
let's say whatever that means,
and it doesn't mean being happy,
they see the reason it can mean being
happiest.
There's gonna be times in your life
where you're going to be called on to
act when you're not happy.
So for example,
when one of your parents dies,
you're going to make a choice.
You're not going to be happy.
That will not be,
oh well,
hopefully you won't be otherwise.
You're tangled in some sort of Freud a
nightmare,
but let's assume that that's not the
case.
You're not going to be happy about it.
You're going to be hurt and maybe even
partly broken.
So what the hell are you supposed to do
then?
Well,
the answer is you should be more use
than trouble under some certain under
such circumstances,
and that's a good thing to strive for.
You know,
because your mother is going to be.
If it's your father,
your mother is going to be equally
distraught and sore,
your siblings and everyone else you care
for.
Maybe by that time you should be tough
enough so that in that situation you're
good for something.
Someone has to make the damn funeral
arrangements.
Someone has to settle out the will.
Someone has to make sure the family
doesn't degenerate into horrific
squabbling,
which is something that often happens
after the death of a
and you're not going to be motivated to
do that by happiness and what if you
have a sick child when you're.
When you're a parent,
maybe it's a chronic illness.
You are not going to be happy about
that.
You know,
it'll be a weight that you carry with
you all the time and it's.
It's,
it's one of those things that seems
particularly unjust.
It's like,
okay,
well you're no longer happy with being
happy is the purpose of life.
Well then you're basically.
That's pretty much it for you,
isn't it?
And you know these catastrophes that I'm
speaking of,
you can.
You can be certain that you're going to
be exposed to many of those during your
life.
You know,
it'll be a rare period.
I think it's a rare period in anyone's
life where one or more of such things
isn't going on chronically.
If it's not you with some terrible
health problem or some other terrible
problem,
then it's a parent or a sibling or a
child or because you know you're
connected to other people and they're
vulnerable to.
So that's the law of human beings and so
if it's happiness,
and this is what Solzhenitsyn said about
happiness to it's said happiness is a
philosophy who's brought to ruin by the
first blow of a guard's truncheon.
It's like,
yeah,
that's.
That's about as bluntly as you can put
it.
Here's another.
I have time to read both of these.
I think this is from character guard as
well.
Kierkegaard,
by the way,
was really the first thinker who
identified what we would describe in
modern terms as anxiety,
especially as existential existential
anxiety or anxious,
you know,
when it would be associated with the
condition of questioning the nature of
existence,
the utility of existence,
and so kierkegaard was really the first
person who formalized that into
something
resembling a philosophy or a psychology,
and then he was trying to think of how,
how that might be overcome given that it
seemed to be rooted,
in fact,
in factual observation that that's the
observation of suffering
and this is a corollary to Dostoyevsky's
comments.
Even though character guards,
comments were written decades earlier.
Dostoyevsky's critique basically said
you can't solve the problem of suffering
by formalizing a utopia and then joining
it like a mass animal.
You can't do that because you're not
that kind of creature.
Even if it was possible,
you wouldn't accept it.
You'd cause trouble because you're
interested in trouble.
You're probably more interested in,
in trouble than you are and being happy.
So I mean,
you know,
people like that,
that's another marker often have serious
personality disorder,
right?
I have clients have many of them who are
way more interested in causing trouble
in some way than they are and being
boring and stable.
They'll take any form of suffering and
inflict any form of suffering on any
number of people they can possibly get
their hooks into in order to merely to
escape,
you know,
drab and secure normality.
You know,
you call those people dramatic,
overly dramatic.
That's one way of looking at it and they
make as far as I can tell,
a relatively conscious choice.
Trouble is more interesting than safety.
Character Guard says something similar,
but in a,
in a more,
in a more pop,
in a morph,
what would you say in a manner that's
more constructive in some sense with
regards to what you should do with all
that in St Energy,
that you're not going to be able to
encapsulate inside a utopia and it has
to do with individual responsibility.
There is a view of life which conceives
that where the crowd is,
there is also the truth and that in
truth itself,
there is need of having the crowd on its
side.
I was on a panel at one point about,
I think we were discussing gender
differences between obviously between
men and women and there are lots of
people,
the social constructionist in particular
who think that all of the differences,
there's biological sex and then there's
gender and gender is socially
constructed and that all gender
differences are socially constructed and
there's no biological differences in
gender between the two sexes.
Now virtually no evidence supports that
proposition.
If you look at the hardcore
psychological evidence,
in fact,
it's completely the opposite and not
only that,
as you make societies more egalitarian,
men and women get more different instead
of more of the same.
Now the reason that happens is because
once the iron out the environmental
variability,
by equalizing everything,
all that's left is genetic vulnerable
variability and so it springs to the
forefront and so the biggest gender
differences in the world are between men
and women in Scandinavia and those are
partly personality differences.
Women are higher in negative emotion and
more agreeable among other things,
but more particularly,
the differences seem to be a those of
interest.
So the biggest differences between men
and women seem to be in what they're
interested in and roughly speaking,
women are more interested in people and
roughly speaking,
men are more interested in things.
And so in Scandinavia for example,
you have a 20 to one proportion of women
to men in nursing and at 21 to one
proportion of men to women in
engineering and so and you know the
Scandinavian governments now and then
try to move that.
So there's more male nurses and more
female engineers and if they really push
they can move.
The ratio is somewhat for a few years.
But as soon as they relax they snap
right back to 20 to one.
So anyways,
I was saving some of these studies and
one of the people that I was discussing
said,
well what are we supposed to do with
that?
And I said,
well,
I don't know what you mean.
Those are,
those are scientific findings said,
yeah,
but truth has to be established by
consensus.
And I thought,
I don't want to live in whatever world
you're going to end up ruling because
truth is not merely established by
consensus or if you think it does and
you think it is,
then while you're in the position that
character guard describes,
which is that as long as everyone else
believes that the appropriate thing is
for you to believe it.
And also that's the truth.
It's like it's a pretty damn dismal
philosophy and it gets people into
tremendous trouble because no matter how
many people think there isn't a wall
there,
anyone who runs out it had first is in
for a vicious surprise.
There's a view of life which conceives
that where the crowd is there is also
the truth and in that truth,
it's an in truth itself.
There is need of having the crowd on its
side.
There's another view of life which
conceives that.
Wherever there is a crowd,
there is untruth
so that to consider for a moment the
extreme case,
even if every individual each for
himself in private,
we're to be in possession of the truth.
Yet in case they're all to get together
in a crowd,
a crowd to which any sort of decisive
significance as attributed,
avoiding voting,
noisy,
audible crowd untruth would immediately
be in evidence
for crowd is untruth in a godly sense.
It is true eternally Christianly as St
Paul says,
that only one attains the goal which is
not meant in a comparative sense for
comparison takes others into account.
It means that every individual can be
that one God helping him there in,
but only one attains the goal and again,
this means that every man should be
careful about having to do with the
others and essentially should only talk
with God in himself,
for only one attains the goal,
and again this means that man or to be a
man is akin to daddy in a worldly and
temporal sense.
It will be said by the man of bustle,
sociability and amicable illness.
How unreasonable that only one attains
the goal for it is far more likely that
many by the strength of united effort
should attain the goal and when we are
many successes more certain and it is
easier for each man severally.
True enough,
it is far more likely and it is also
true with respect to all earthly and
material goods,
if it is allowed to have its way.
However,
this becomes the only true point of view
for desert way with God in eternity in
man's kinship with Daddy.
It does away with it or transforms it
into a fable and puts in its place the
modern,
or we might say the old pagan notion
that to be a man is to belong to a race,
endowed with reason to belong to it as a
specimen so that the race or species is
higher than the individual.
This is a hundred years before nazi-ism,
which is to say that there are more no
more individuals,
but only specimens,
but eternity which arches over at high
above the temporal tranquil as the story
vault at night and God in heaven.
Who in the bliss of that sublime
tranquility holds in survey without the
least sense of dizziness at such a
height.
Those countless multitudes of men and
knows each single individual by name.
He the great examiner says that only one
attains the goal.
Kierkegaard was a Christian
existentialist Protestant.
Dusty [inaudible] was an Orthodox
Christian,
existentialist and Nicha who was also an
existentialist,
was a perhaps the most effective anti
Christian philosopher who's ever
existed,
and he made it one of his
conscious aims to take a hammer to
everything that was foundational against
what was left of what was left at
Christianity at the time that he
existed.
And the reason I'm telling you this is
because existentialism is a strange
philosophical.
It's a strange philosophy.
It brings people with very divergent
fundamental assumptions.
Together they share certain assumptions,
and one assumption is that life in its
essence is suffering,
and the second is that the individual
has a responsibility to adopt
responsibility in faith in the face of
that suffering and that that's the
proper response.
The proper response isn't nihilism or
ideological possession.
It's something else.
It's something that depends on the
person themselves.
Nature draws the same conclusions as
Kierkegaard.
A traveler who had seen many countries
in people's
and several continents was asked what
human traits he had found everywhere,
and he answered.
Men Are inclined to laziness.
Some will feel that he might've said
with greater justice,
they're all timid.
They hide behind customs and opinions
at bottom.
Every human being knows very well that
he is in this world just once as
something unique and then no accident,
however strange we'll throw together a
second time into a unity such a curious
and diffuse perilla,
plurality.
He knows it,
but hides it like a bad conscience.
Why?
The last lecture when we're talking
about Roger's not the video lecture,
but the last time I was talking to you
about Rogers,
I was talking about instrumental speech
and that's the speech that you engage
in.
It's inauthentic from a Rogerian
existentialist perspective when the goal
of this speech is to extract something
from someone or something.
The goal is not mere clarity of
communication and so what that means is
that the speech becomes separate from
the person and the speech is being used
as a tool for what some element of the
person requires and that's the hiding
behind convention that niche is talking
about because
when people use instrumental speech,
they're almost always pursuing something
that other people have told them that
they should want.
It might be status,
it might be career promotion.
It might be,
well those are,
those are two of the two of the major.
It might be material progress of other
sorts,
but it's only.
It's only the problem is is that it's
only part of the person talking
and that part is the part gets fixated
on that local achievement.
It's not the part that is attempting to
inquire about what the truth might be in
this particular situation and to
describe it as carefully as possible and
that's the clearest speech of the
individual.
Now,
one of the premises of existential
psychotherapy is that that's the only
way you can be healthy.
You have to learn to speak and act as a
whole and your.
You have to be directed towards
responsibility and truth and the
consequences of not doing that will be a
that you will suffer pointlessly,
which is the worst kind of suffering and
b,
which is worse.
You'll bring rack and ruin onto everyone
around you and it gets worse than that
actually,
because if you do that long enough,
not only will you bring rock and ruin on
everyone around you,
you'll want to,
and that seems at least potentially like
a bad outcome.
Well,
you can say,
if you adopt a firm belief system that
will protect you from that,
it's like the terror management idea of
ideology protecting you from,
from death anxiety,
which is a,
it's a very hopeless philosophy that
because it basically suggests that the
only people reason people have beliefs
is because they're terrified without
them and that if they engage in any sort
of heroic behavior,
it's merely a
facade that in the final analysis is
empty.
Although necessary.
That's where the idea of positive
illusion came from.
Essentially,
you know that life is so terrible that
enlist you lie yourself into
tranquility.
You'll be mentally unstable and
unhealthy.
Uh,
a doctrine for which,
by the way,
there is no real evidence,
in fact,
the what
anyways,
from fear of his neighbor who insists on
convention and veils himself with it.
But what is it that compels the
individual human being to fear his
neighbor,
to think and act heard fashion and not
to be glad of himself as sense of shame,
perhaps in a few rare cases in the vast
majority,
it is the desire for comfort,
inertia in short,
that inclination to laziness of which
the traveler spoke.
He's right.
Men are even than they are timid,
and what they fear most is the troubles
with which any unconditional honesty and
nudity would burden them.
Only artists hate this slovenly life and
borrowed manners and loosely fitting
opinions and unveiled the secret.
Everyone's bad conscience.
The principle that every human being is
a unique wonder.
They dare to show us the human being as
he is down to the last muscle himself
and himself alone.
Even more.
That in this rigorous consistency of his
uniqueness,
he is beautiful and worth contemplating
as novel and incredible as every work of
nature and by no means dull.
When a great thinker despises man,
it's their laziness that he despises
for.
It is an account on.
It is on account of this that they have
the appearance of factory products and
appear indifferent and not worthy of
companionship or instruction.
The human being who does not wish to
belong to the mass must merely cease
being comfortable with himself.
Let him follow his conscience,
which shouts at him.
Be Yourself.
What you're presently doing,
opining,
and desiring
that is not really you.
Okay.
That's good place to start.
See you Thursday.